a lame ass man that's got nothing in his  life and just feeds off you  the bare minimum from a girl  how can you clean  but you should do that what do you tell  a young girl who says I want to be  president I would say do it all of the  women that say men ain't [ __ ] and men  are trashed should they all be banned  too so different so different  yes and that is recent time compared to  hundreds of years what do you guys think  of Andrew Tate  they don't have a point to freeze they  just same things that benefit them  well I believe in Princess treatment no  one's perfect but I'm close for me I  wouldn't go with a guy who had no money  all they deserve is nothing I leave here  goodbye Rebecca you've slept with the  whole football team she has your [ __ ]  ready okay no ironing though that's too  far